good
[Music]
happy friday greets héctor mejía
with his brief news today
nevada enters phase 2 of the
reopening plan this means that many more
businesses can reopen their doors to the
public this list includes bars
gyms spas massage services
swimming pools  cinemas and museums also
indoor malls must
continue to respect social distancing guidelines
meanwhile thousands of members of
the culinary union will take to the streets to
protest today they will be the las
vegas strip this is a video of a caravan they
did at the beginning of the month  they plan to
do another one to demand that the
casinos share their reopening plans and
implement strict
protection measures for workers and
employees
the caravan will start at 5 in the
afternoon
[Music]
there you have the new team the
henderson nights on  owner of the call
the nights fall and said that the
organization has been working on
putting an equ  minor league ipo here
since last year and now we go to
your weather forecast we will have another
day of extreme heat but also
some winds through the day
temperatures will reach around
107 degrees the nineties come this
weekend and the  next week have a
great friday hello to héctor
mejía and this was the insead in spanish
[Music]